Ngoài nguồn này 1 tăng bởi năng kai nghỉ khu chăm ha mi sấu,
công an tính đặc lắc phát đi thung báo để nghĩ hỗ trợ cuông cấp thung tinh
phục cụ lưu chào của an sích người tại phường buồn mà thuật.
Theo đó, các quan tính rất đời chào công an tính đặc đặc thủ lý đu chào của an sích người
trên ra, lúc 1 tám dự năm 2020, hãy tháng bởi năng kai nghỉ khu chăm ha mi sấu
tại khu vực chức nhà số 1 trong bởi mấy sấu đường trên như rật, phường buồn mà thuật.
Đây là vụ an có tính chất đặc biệt nghiêm trọng.
Ná nhân được sất định là ông hát hát hát, sinh năm 2020, trở bị mấy chiến
từ vong tại hiện trường. Sau khi về an, đối tượng đánh những trong tổ thóc.
Theo khi nhận mà đầu, đối tượng kế an là năng dưới,
các khoảng tường 1 mấy sấu mấy tư để một mấy bình,
mặc áo đồng phục dài tây mổ xanh của háng quát,
cười dinh mổ xanh, đối mối bởi mở hình mổ xanh ra,
đi zếp, phương tệ đối tượng sự dụng có đặc biển giống xếm một tồ hòa đại emyết mổ đò.
Trắng, chưa sất định miền kiểm soát,
sau khi về an, cho khoảng hình tổ thóc, đối tượng đã thể áo khó đường phục quá bầu xanh bằng áo khóc mổ trường xám.
Để phục vụ công tác đều tra, chiến sất đối tượng,
cơ quan kể rất đều tra công an tính đáp lắc định nghĩ các cơ quan,
đối chức phản giác dân tích cực vối hộ,
kì thời cụ có tương tình khi phát hiện đối tượng hòa mấy chiếm một khó bởi vì vĩnh giữa đối tượng đối qua đến vua an.
Mọi tông tin sinh lên hiện đồng sĩ đại tả phán thình cờ,
trường phòng cạnh rất hiện sự, địa thoại không chính không năm,
hai, ba, chính, hai bày, chính, đồng sĩ chúng ta hòa của khán phó trường phòng tham yêu,
địa thoại không chính bày muốn, khó, khó, bốn, bày, bốn, bày, hoặc các quản công an cần nhất để vối hợp sức mình,
chiếc sét, phát sữa đối tượng. Công an tính đặc lắc hình cảm ạng bị báo trẻ,
trước trước đối tượng phạm tội hòa cần trường hòa đậm đều tra,
trên bắt sẽ bị sử liên nghiên thật với định của pháp lật.
Rất mong cổ đồng mạng xe sẻ thông tin giống giải đến ở dân,
qua đó, giúp cơ quan công an yên trong tình ra hông tụ để trường chiếc pháp lật.